The hockey mask-wearing, machete-toting Jason
Voorhees has terrorized unsuspecting teens
since Friday the 13th hit screens in 1980.
The franchise has produced 12 movies, a TV
show, a series of comics, and a few brutal
video games…but audiences still want more.
Take a look behind the mask to see how he
became one of the most recognizable movie
monsters of all time.
Here's the untold truth of Friday the 13th.
Save the date
Following his work on Wes Craven's The Last
House on the Left, director/producer Sean
Cunningham sought to capitalize on the growing
slasher movie trend.
In a pretty brilliant marketing move, Cunningham
took out an ad promoting the film before he
had any financial backing.
He called the unscripted film Friday the 13th,
mimicking the date-specific theme set by the
Halloween series.
The strategy worked, and as word spread of
what the ads called "the most terrifying movie
ever made," investors actually started reaching
out to him.
He found himself with a budget for a film
with a title — but no plot or characters.
So why Friday the 13th?
"Jason was my son, and today is his birthday."
Joshua Voorhees?
Miller originally wrote the character of Jason
Voorhees as "Josh," but changed it to avoid
giving him the same name as his own son, Joshua.
And because, really, Josh Takes Manhattan
probably wouldn't have quite the same ring
to it.
At the time, the character's name had little
significance—he wasn't even written to appear
in the film until later drafts, and even then,
only in his mother's dream sequences.
Masked Maniac
Jason didn't take his iconic, masked form
until Friday the 13th: Part III.
While the original character was created by
screenwriter Victor Miller and director Sean
S. Cunningham, the hockey mask was a contribution
from Part III director Steve Miner to replace
Jason's usual burlap sack.
"Steve had done a whole bunch of hockey documentaries
when he was learning the editing craft.
And I think that just out of that he said
'well let's at least try this.'
And that was the choice for Friday 3 and it
just stuck."
The mask worn by Jason in Part III was replicated
from a Detroit Red Wings goalie mask, and
variations appeared throughout the rest of
the series.
Miner's suggestion of the hockey mask secured
Jason as an iconic figure, making him the
master of terror that we know today.
Camp Crystal Lake
Camp No-Be-Bo-Sco, or the North Bergen Boy
Scouts camp, and has been operational since
1927, but you might know it better as Camp
Crystal Lake.
The New Jersey summer camp runs regular day
tours of the grounds to satisfy the curiosities
of horror fans, but No-Be-Bo-Sco is otherwise
reserved exclusively for Boy Scout activities.
According to the official site, the hundred
dollar tickets sell out quickly, but they're
good for a five-hour guided tour of all the
key massacre locations.
If you can't make it out to Jason's bloodstained
stomping grounds, you can buy a chunk of the
original Camp Crystal Lake dock, a slice of
log cabin, or a bottle of water from the lake
in which young Jason famously drowned.
Mommy
Friday the 13th's signature sound cue is actually
the voice of composer Harry Manfredini.
Cunningham approached Manfredini to create
a musical cue that would characterize the
presence of the unseen psycho.
Manfredini took a cue from the film itself,
when Jason's mother utters those terrifying
words...
Manfredini repeated the words, applied a heavy
reverb to his voice, and the result became
iconic.
The effect that was initially created to foreshadow
Mrs. Voorhees would cue the presence of Jason
in all the new films to follow.
A new car
After failing to cast Shelley Winters for
the role of Mrs. Voorhees, the production
team sought out veteran television actress
Betsy Palmer, who initially turned it down
upon reading the script, which she thought
was awful.
Palmer eventually caved and took the role
because she desperately needed a new car.
"And truly I only did the darn thing to buy
a car, I really did."
At the end of filming, she could afford a
Volkswagen Scirocco.
She changed her mind after production began
when effects artist Tom Savini showed her
some pictures of his effects work.
When a picture of the effects for the young,
deformed Jason came up, he told her, "That's
your son."
From that point on, Palmer gained sympathy
for Pamela Voorhees and delivered a performance
that would become a milestone of her career.
"Hahahaha chechecheche"
Best body count
Jason's victims have been tallied at numbers
ranging between 158 and 300, but it's still
unanimous that Jason is responsible for more
onscreen fatalities than any of his horror
villain contemporaries.
The wide margin of error is attributed to
Mrs. Voorhees being the original maniac, a
grief-sick father emulating Jason in Part
V, and because much of his body count in Freddy
Vs. Jason are attributable to Freddy via mind
control.
Even the lower-end figure lands Jason miles
ahead of Freddy Krueger, Michael Myers, or
Leatherface.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
Friday the 13th film is your favorite...